antoine cléroux en direct de moscou
antoine bonjour alors l'admirent poutine
at il livré davantage de détail de piste
sur le déconfinement à venir en russie
où le président russe a annoncé la fin
de la période chômée au niveau national
à partir de ce mardi 12 mai cette mesure
qu inciter la population à respecter le
confinement aura donc duré six semaines
mais cela ne veut pas dire que la menace
sanitaire s'éloigne pour autant je vous
propose d'écouter vladimir poutine
[Musique]
présente au mans sarthe à partir de
mardi 12 mai la période de chômage pour
tous les secteurs et tous le monde
s'achève mais la lutte contre l'épidémie
n'est pas terminée
notamment dans les territoires où la
situation est plus ou moins
satisfaisante
donc il faut être bien attentif qui est
au lycée il ne faut pas revenir en
arrière il faut éviter une deuxième
vague et de nouvelles complications pour
ceux qui sont déjà malades à qatana
épidémie le régime de déconfinement ne
sera pas rapide il faut un certain temps
donc à partir du 12 mai jusqu'à la levée
complète du déconfinement il est très
important de suivre toutes les mesures
qui ont été dictées et les mesures
complémentaires éventuelles
temps gris ne pas une idée préférant
tylski mourir idiot il ne s'agit donc
que d'une première étape
on peut davantage comprendre cette
annonce comme un assouplissement
progressif du confinement est encore un
assouplissement qui n'est pas généralisé
à l'ensemble du pays à moscou par
exemple qui reste le principal foyer de
cette pandémie
le confinement était étendu la semaine
dernière par le maire de la capitale
jusqu'au 31 mai il est donc du ressort
de chaque région de décider de son
calendrier de déconfinement en fonction
de la situation de la situation sur
place et en suivant les recommandations
des autorités sanitaires mais à partir
de demain
vladimir poutine l'a dit partout c'est
possible il faut créer les conditions
pour la reprise du travail dans les
secteurs de base de l'économie comme le
bâtiment l'industrie l'agriculture les
télécommunications l'énergie ou encore
l'extraction de matières premières car
ces longues semaines de confinement ont
grandement mise à mal l'économie russe
avec un chiffre pour en témoigner
le nombre de chômeurs déclarés a doublé
depuis début avril a dit mir poutine a
donc annoncé un nouvel ensemble de
mesures pour soutenir l'économie des
mesures fiscales en particulier mais
aussi à destination des ménages comme
par exemple des allocations
supplémentaires pour les femmes
enfin le président a défendu l' approche
russe de dépistage massif ducobu 19 qui
permet d'après lui une meilleure prise
en charge des patients afin également de
les isoler du reste de la population
merci beaucoup antoine pour tous ces
précisions antoine claireaux en direct
de moscou